c'est pareil déjà cinq heures et est
thématique femmes qui qui vient me
chercher à ça à la sortie des du du
palais et bah va pas trouver de place a
encore avant encore s'énerver pipi
puisse faire ça va encore être là la
soupe à la grimace à eybens à coup de
chance et c'est le même avocat qui va
plaider les deux affaires s'il pouvait
aller vite ça m'arrangerai à bonjour
bonjour m alors voilà un maître dit moi
je suis assez pressé alors les trois
accusés ne sont pas là alors par défaut
tous tous les trois alors si vous
pouviez fond c'est ça m'arrangerait
couvrement saad haddad accord tête elles
à la flèche rapide par à 12h beau
bondirait dans l'espace bcc dia pour
vous à plaisir parce que d'habitude
j'aime peut peser chaque mot
maintenant voilà autre chose fugate
toujours comme ça abbas a alors assez
bizarre vous êtes deux premiers qui ne
s'en soit rendu compte il me why me
ibrahim bahit la rive de payer comme ça
quand j'ai trop fou faux fourvoyé avec
les femmes
alors moi voiler les femmes d'un couple
up sa coupe et coupe la parole
reid didot vous avez un sacré à rennes
et êtes-vous pourquoi se dit pourquoi
cette d'ipic aimant stupide père moi ça
ou paille curieux ça serait plutôt le
contraire c'est le manque de rapport
avec ma femme qui me fait bébé pays
comme ça d'ailleurs ce que vous voyez là
michael kenna vous comprendriez abbey et
s'amuser pas aidé été étonnant quand on
voit votre google avoue vous et vous
aimez vous savez ça ne me gêne pas parce
que quand quand on voit celle de
gainsbourg
ça vous angoisse ça marche pas mal pour
lui un bon allez trève de plaisanterie o
comment vous appelez-vous alphonse des
premières troupes butter interactif qui
voilà alors si vous permettez pour aller
plus plus vite je vais vous appeler al
alphonse france zhao aussi vite qu e
bonds à l'épreuve premier à faire
affaire là n'arrivent qu'est ce qui lie
la fée boîte votre larible 1-1 insultes
à agent rachid avant alors qu'est ce
qu'il a dit exactement la wilaya il a
écrit et qui m'auront veut mort où vous
allez craquer calmez vous je comprends
votre émotion mais mauvais il y avait là
des membres est mort vers 5h d'install
la vache
la mairie de le dire la quéquette qu'est
ce que je dis que c'est exactement j'ai
dit 5 5h10 mais la face de vous rappeler
quelque est ce que j'ai dit mais la
fasch vous mêlez fait exprès wii u n'est
pas au pied de voile et peut pas partir
ce que j'ai dit et deux mois avec deux
mois avec deux mois deux mois faire je
suis dacc moi je suis die penser à
écouter j'ai pas beaucoup de temps vous
m'en voyez le respar pneumatiques de de
demain matin des bombes est à dallas des
ayatollahs fermes auront xala et
qu'elles évitent qu'est ce qui a fait
votre homme mange très bien fichu il
fumait de la mariée il suivit fut mais
d'abord il fait varier la marine québec
et mari de fanny sirop hanna ont la main
marijuana alors 2 2 en fait à 90 a pas
on va te demandes ce client qui aiment
tient à coeur à la dudh était désolé ce
genre de truc je n'admets pas 2,2
enfants d'adam kaikai cas calmez vous
mangez juba pays bas plaidoiries à
palumbo 87 pages après après jeu rapide
comme la veille ouais ouais je sais
pourquoi de salon pour gros profité 2 2
de la situation pas parce que ma femme
est attendu autour du pal du bon aller
1-1 dans un drame un homme dodge des
coups comme oh comment commencer ma pipe
line noir il pourra aller on va
s'arranger six 6 mois donc vous pouvez
crever non mes yeux non messieurs pas
aller à un bain un mois merde c'est pas
beaucoup un mémoire
panda ta gueule non messieurs bon je
leur ai dit allez allez on a hâte
allez allez allez les vioques aller à
gracc acapulco
à dupont tuera les dagues acquis actu
peut parler trempé pour lui de 2,2 en
faire avant sheila j'ai jamais pu dire à
acquitter menu ne passe jamais plus y
est c'est fini c'est curieux ça y est
c'est fini